some people are born to be stars which
is why they go straight from the crib to
Hollywood we're about to take a closer
look at some of the most promising
actresses Hollywood's got to offer and
their ages just might shock you watch
until the end to find out which 15 year
old actress is set to become the biggest
star of her generation Yara Shahidi Yara
Shahidi might only be 19 years old but
her portfolio is already super
impressive the Millenial fell in love
with acting when she was a kid which led
her to audition for the role of Candace
West when she was only 7 years old after
landing this small part on the hit
series entourage Yara spirits were at an
all-time high leading her to audition
for as many roles as possible for the
next seven years
Yara continued to follow her dreams and
was soon rewarded with the role of a
lifetime in 2014 she was cast as Zoe
Johnson on this super popular TV show
blackish and well the rest is pretty
much history the award-winning series
brought her to Fame in a blink of an eye
and she's not complaining on top of
being an excellent actress Yara is also
found as being a voice artist yetis
don't exist oh and did we mention she's
an incredible dancer too but seriously
is there anything that she can't do Yara
was featured in Drake's music video nice
for what where she can be seen busting a
move or two the past few years have
brought yards career to an all-time high
and she deserves every drop of theme
that comes her way if you want to see
more of this actress you're in luck
because she's starring in the Sun is
also a star which should be hitting the
big screen in 2019 Elsie Fisher next on
the list is Elsie Fisher who is living
proof that you're never too young to
follow your dreams she became an actress
at 5 years old after landing a small
role on the TV series medium but things
really started to pick up for Elsie when
she breached the voice acting fields her
adorable high-pitched voice led her to
audition for 2010's Despicable Me and
soon after Elsie was cast as Agnes
the movies great success launched her
career in the right direction and now
the teens portfolio speaks for itself
despite her young age Elsie's had the
chance to work alongside some pretty big
actors like Kevin Costner and Steve
Carell hold on a second
that's not Steve Carell that's bull
aeneas GRU ah there you go much better
Elsie's currently working on the
upcoming film The Addams Family in which
she'll be playing the role of Parker
Kneedler and we don't know about you but
we're pretty excited to catch the highly
anticipated film in theaters joey king
she's talented hilarious and everything
you'd want in a best friend which is why
people her age can't get enough of her
Joey King brings a whole new meaning to
the word inspiring and she does this
solely by being herself the kissing
booth star is no newbie when it comes to
snagging big time roles which is why
she's currently working on two different
productions so keep an eye out for camp
and Zero Vil because Joey's performances
are always worth the watch so we entered
the acting industry in 2006 and got the
chance to work alongside the Cole twins
on the suite life of zack & cody but she
didn't stick around the family channel
for too long however she did manage to
work with Selena Gomez in Ramona and
Beezus before joining the Hollywood
squad did you guys know that Joey and
Selena are great friends in fact the two
stars consider themselves to be like
sisters
Joey's a big superhero fan which compels
her to do her own stunts from time to
time so believe it or not but she
performed every single stunt that came
her way while filming the movie
quarantine storm Reed when it comes to
working on big productions let's just
say that storm Reed got an early start
as soon as she was old enough to form
sentences storm started begging her
parents to take her to auditions it
didn't take long for directors to
realize that storm had a knack for
getting into character which is why she
was cast as Emily in 12 years to slaves
so by the time storm turned ten years
old she already had an oscar-winning
movie on her resume she may only be 15
years old today but she's got enough
credits to make a 40-year old actor
squeal with jealousy by now many of you
probably recognize this actress from the
hit movie
a wrinkle in time and to be honest we'd
be shocked if you did it
storm played her character Meg with
flawless charm and most importantly she
got to work alongside the one and only
Oh Brad stay together
don't let anyone separate although the
average teenager would be intimidated to
work with oscar-winning actors like
Reese Witherspoon and Lupita Nyong'o
storm never lets her nerves get the best
of her so all in all it's safe to say
that this girl's a professional storm is
currently working on a miniseries called
central park 5 which is set to come out
in 2019 so if you want to see more of
her you won't have to wait too long
Jenna Ortega next up is the adorable
Jenna Ortega the 17 year old actress
isn't natural when it comes to acting in
front of the camera which is why the
Disney Channel didn't hesitate to give
her a contract Jenna started acting when
she was 10 years old and quite frankly
she hasn't stopped since she's had the
opportunity to work on big productions
like Iron Man 3 insidious chapter 2 and
Jane the virgin but anyone who knows and
loves Jenna knows that she got her big
break by landing the leading role of
Harley Diaz in stuck in the middle this
Disney Channel classic quickly became a
fan favorite and sooner than later Jenna
became a huge deal on top of being a
talented actress Jenna also dabbles in
voice acting so if you're a fan of Elena
of avalor you'll be happy to know that
Jenna voices the character Princess
Isabel
let's give an extra warm welcome to
princess Isabel although the young star
might take her career very seriously
she's sort of a prankster in real life
so much so that she confessed to
replacing her friend's deodorant stick
with butter during a sleepover so while
her schedule might be jam-packed Jenna
knows how to have a good laugh
marseilles Martin Marcy Martin might be
a big-time star but she's not too
different from the average person the 14
year old actress comes off much older
than she is due to her awesome fashion
style and mature personality but don't
be fooled by her amazing acting skills
because the girls still a teeny bopper
where say is close friends with Yara
which isn't too surprising considering
that they play sisters on the hit TV
series blackish here's a fun fact for
you
stardom is in Marcy's blood after all
her uncle
Bayley is a member of the renowned band
Earth Wind and Fire
Marseille started acting when she was
five years old and she's managed to join
some pretty big productions the young
star has made appearances in films like
fun mom dinner and Nina and she's just
getting started
despite being a major foodie Marseille
admitted to being obsessed with putting
pineapple on pizza which is a big no-no
for some people so if you and her have
this in common make sure to come in a
pizza emoji in the comments section
below
Skye Jackson Skye Jackson is 16 years
old and ready to take on the world
the young star began her acting career
when she was only 3 years old and
quickly realized that performing was
something she couldn't get enough of
Skye became a well-known celebrity when
she joined the Disney Channel family in
2010 she's known for playing Zuri Ross
on the hit TV series like Jesse and
bunk'd although her character might be a
little uptight at times Skye is nothing
like this in real life and although she
might know how to have fun she also
knows when to speak up which is why she
became an internet sensation at only 14
years old around this time the actress
began a Twitter battle with the
opinionated Azealia Banks and believe it
or not she won on top of that Skye's
classic facial expressions made her a
meme overnight which is why most people
can easily spot her out of a crowd she's
highly relatable and super funny making
her a theme favorite she's currently
working on the animated film Peter Pan
land of forever which will be released
sometime in 2019 Bailey Madison is there
anyone as hilarious as the talented
Bailey Madison we highly doubt it the 19
year old actress was born to be on the
big screen and she won't stop until
she's a member of Hollywood's elite club
and by the way things are going it
shouldn't take too long for her to get
there
Bailey started acting when she was only
seven years old and before long she
landed a role in the film Bridge to
Terabithia although she might be young
she's far from being considered a newbie
after all her portfolio is already
beyond impressive although she might
have appeared in some Disney Channel
series fairly quickly upped her game and
landed roles in big-time productions she
worked alongside actors like Adam
Sandler Jennifer Aniston
in nicole kidman which is like a pretty
big deal but when it comes down to it
Bailey is totally down-to-earth and
friendly so basically she doesn't let
them get to her head this isn't
surprising though especially since her
life motto is be humble stay humble and
have fun
McKenna grace have you ever seen anyone
more adorable than McKenna Grace well we
sure haven't at only 12 years old
McKenna is well on her way to becoming
one of the biggest stars in Hollywood
and well we're not exactly surprised
while she might have started her acting
career by playing younger versions of
big-time actors McKenna soon landed a
role on the soap opera The Young and the
Restless which helped her to get her
foot in the door
since then McKenna was able to work with
producers like Steven Spielberg and
Craig Gillespie which isn't something
everyone can say the young star is
already in high demand and she's not
even a teenager yet she's gone from
being a part-time Disney Channel actress
to landing big gigs on Netflix you might
recognize her as a young CEO from the
Netflix original the haunting of Hill
House or as rose from fuller house the
sky's the limit for the natural-born
actress who is currently working on
three different movies Millie Bobby
Brown and last but not least is the
incredibly talented Millie Bobbie Brown
who is barely 15 years old
the English actress knew that she wanted
to become an American superstar since
she was a young kid which is why she
started mimicking the American accent
from a young age watching hours of the
Disney Channel finally paid off and
Millie quickly began auditioning for the
big-time roles this star got her big
break when she landed the role of 11 on
stranger things and the rest is pretty
much history she's a brilliant actress
who knows how to use her emotions as
fuel Millie is currently working on the
movie Godzilla king of monsters so make
sure to keep an eye out for this highly
anticipated film hello so there you have
it guys the top 10 actresses under 20
years old before you go let us know
which one of these stars is your
favorite and that's a wrap make sure to
hit that subscribe button to be the
first in line to watch our newest videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]